hidden away in the mountains of Northern
New Mexico lay one of the most secretive
military projects in history the
Manhattan Project was the code name for
the U.S government's program to develop
the world's first atomic bomb it was so
secretive that President Roosevelt
wasn't fully informed of all the
technical details Vice President Truman
didn't know it existed until after he
became president many members of
Congress didn't know it existed until
after World War II the bomb was
assembled in Los Alamos New Mexico which
housed the main research laboratory for
developing and testing nuclear weapons
scientists worked to harness the energy
of the atom to build the most
destructive weapon humankind had ever
seen and they had to move quickly in
1938 scientists in a lab in Berlin had
managed to split the uranium atom the
energy released from the splitting or
fission is enough to power a bomb
Einstein was worried that the Nazis
might be developing nuclear weapons so
he sent a letter to Roosevelt which
convinced the president to initiate the
American effort to build an atomic bomb
in a bizarre twist Einstein was actually
not allowed to work on the Manhattan
Project because he was a left-leaning
political activist and deemed a security
risk General Leslie Groves appointed one
of the world's top theoretical
physicists to lead the Manhattan Project
which began in 1943. J Robert
Oppenheimer was a well-known instructor
at both the University of California at
Berkeley and the California Institute of
Technology he hand-picked most of the
Los Alamos staff personally traveling to
the best universities Across America to
recruit top scientists Oppenheimer chose
New Mexico for the site's location
because of its natural beauty Los Alamos
in particular was ideal for a top secret
project because it's situated on an
isolated plateau and the spariously
populated location was safer in case of
a nuclear accident the U.S army
purchased over 40 000 acres of land
surrounding a private all boys prep
school and immediately began to build
the community at its peak about ten
thousand scientists engineers
technicians construction workers
military personnel and their families
lived and worked there they enjoyed
hikes throughout the area and attended
parties on the weekends at scientists
residences in the Gated facility a
hodgepodge of laboratory buildings
sprouted up at Los Alamos most of the
equipment was transported by the
scientists themselves to maintain
secrecy Los Alamos was such a secret
City that it wasn't on any map the name
Los Alamos was considered classified
information on paper it was only
referred to as project y operated by the
University of California and no one who
went to live and work there was allowed
to tell their family or friends where
they were going all the incoming mail
was addressed to the same place P.O box
1663 Santa Fe babies born there actually
had that on their birth certificate
Los Alamos wasn't the only location for
the Manhattan Project in Oak Ridge
Tennessee scientists enriched uranium to
fuel a bomb in Washington state reactors
were built to produce plutonium an
entirely new substance that could also
fuel a bomb if you worked at one site
you likely didn't have any idea what was
being done elsewhere or even what the
overall goal of the project was I didn't
know what I was doing I was just doing
it Ruth Huddleston was 18 years old when
she joined the Manhattan Project they
told us when I was in training that we
were not supposed to ever let anything
leave that room we were not supposed to
tell anybody what we were doing not even
to the people that we were working with
Ruth was one of ten thousand young women
who were responsible for ensuring that a
large and complex machine called a
caliotron separated isotopes of uranium
which fueled the bomb kellytron
separated lighter uranium-235 from the
heavier and more common uranium-238
u-235 is highly unstable which makes it
splitable or fissionable when it's
slammed by a neutron it becomes u-236
it's so unstable that it splits into two
atoms in the process more neutrons are
released they slam into more u-235s
causing a chained reaction and a huge
explosion Ruth's job was to monitor the
meters on the kaliatron machine that's
her seated third back on the left they
had a certain range that they wanted
that meter to be you know they told us
if it went too far to the left or too
far to the right it was time for us to
straighten it up and get it back in that
range her job would have normally gone
to a scientist but there weren't enough
of them and young men were fighting
overseas so the government recruited
farm girls most of whom were hired
straight at of high school and they
proved to be better at the job than
scientists scientists were too concerned
with figuring out what had gone wrong
whereas these young women would simply
alert their supervisors when there was
an issue they also didn't overthink any
adjustments that were needed as a
scientist might
if they thought too much and started
asking questions there were consequences
if somebody started being nosy and
wanting to ask you everything and and
wanted to talk too much about it for
some reason they disappeared they lost
their jobs on July 16 1945 Los Alamos
scientists detonated the world's first
nuclear weapon over the New Mexico
desert the implosion style device with
the plutonium core looks like a steel
globe and was nicknamed the gadget which
again speaks to its secrecy it was
similar in design to the fat man bomb
dropped on the Japanese city of negasaki
three weeks later another atomic bomb
had just devastated the Japanese city of
Hiroshima the bombs killed hundreds of
thousands of people from exposure to the
blasts and also from the long-term side
effects of radiation when they first
told us when I first heard it
it really bothered me it upset me
because I realized that I had helped
killed a lot of people
the horror of two atomic bombs convinced
Japanese hardliners to surrender when
the Manhattan Project was finally
revealed to the world many were shocked
to learn that such a large operation
existed in secret at its peak the
Manhattan Project employed a hundred
thirty thousand people and by the end of
the war it had cost 2.2 billion the
equivalent of 36 billion today the
Manhattan Project ultimately led to the
Cold War arms race which brought with it
the possibility of Armageddon and that
possibility haunts the world today
the best and brightest scientists worked
on the Manhattan Project and changed the
course of history if you'd like to brush
up on your science technology
engineering and math skills
brilliant.org is a website and app where
you can learn stem interactively and
it's free for you to try out with my
custom link my viewers love the computer
science courses where you can play along
to learn in this course you have to try
to use as few commands as possible to
deliver mail to every house on the
street while avoiding the rocks or take
a dive into neural networks and discover
how these learning tools actually work
and no previous coding experience is
necessary if you ever get stuck you can
click on show explanation to see where
you went wrong brilliant is great if
you're studying or if you're already
working and want your skills to stay
sharp I like to go through the logic
courses to improve my critical thinking
skills brilliant is free for you to try
out if you head to brilliant.org
newsthink my custom link is in the
description
and the first 200 people who sign up
with my link will get 20 off Brilliance
annual premium subscription which gives
you access to all of their offerings